[Music]
as as i watched this as i'm sure many of
you thought to yourselves i thought to
myself was this always a film was this
ever a play in your mind as you were
coming up with the idea and actually
writing it
how many people are coming
there'll be four of them
richard
linda
this is jay and gail perry
thank you for agreeing to meet us you're
welcome
i'm gonna leave you alone let me know if
you need anything
what would you like to know everything i
want to know everything why
why do i want to know about your son
because he killed mine
it's not our fault richard
[Music]
you know the catalyst was the parkland
shooting and i started researching this
stuff with not the intention of making a
movie but just i felt like i needed to
know what was going on
and so that was february 2018 and i had
my first sort of final draft screenplay
files in a in sort of uh late april may
and then by the summer i had shifted to
a stage play because i felt
initially i just wrote it as a play judy
pulled up to a church and we were in a
parish hall for 90 pages and so i
thought maybe this should be a play but
my heart was set on a movie and
ultimately i shifted back
uh about a about a year later about it
was shortly after february 2019 that i
shifted back to a screenplay it started
as a screenplay started as a screenplay
yeah it was always i i wanted to make a
movie and i wanted to make a movie in a
room in real time
my first sort of emails to people were
you know no no score just practical
music
uh uninterrupted real-time conversation
and because this does feel as intimate
and powerful as a great theater piece
i'd be curious to know
did you all four have the luxury of a
long rehearsal was it a small budget so
that you couldn't what was that process
like and what did you find helpful about
things that the four of you did as a
cast before shooting
we had two and a half days of rehearsal
but what it really was was going through
text to make sure we all
were on the same page so to speak what
story we were telling
that was very helpful
and
what happened over those over those two
and a half days
was uh coming to trust one another and
knowing that we were safe with one
another that's huge
huge
uh
plus we we had all been at it a while
you know
and we had our time in the theater many
many hours in the theater so
i like to say we had our sea legs
and our understanding of
endurance meaning
just to take the breath
and settle in
and then we went away for three weeks to
our separate lives and we came back
and during that period we all did our
personal work
as each actor works differently
learned our words very important
and when we got there we
it seemed to just flow
fran
set it up beautifully
making sure that
all the time in the room was shot
in sequence
uh 10 to 12 pages a day um
once the sun went down our day was
finished that's kind of a lovely feeling
you know we were light dependent
and then we would meet in the evenings
to go over the next day
we were a very cohesive group um
and were entirely comfortable
with this gentleman at the helm
it just made it all possible it shows
fran obviously for your four actors you
had bodies of work to watch
and
i'm sure conversations with them before
hiring them but how did you know in your
heart of hearts that these four
performers
would
sync up and gel as much as they did or
did you have to just take a leap of
faith on that
i i never i never imagined uh actors of
this caliber um doing this i uh
truly beyond beyond my my dreams and
expectations truly um
it it it came together quickly as soon
as i you know i wasn't really getting
the time of day
just sort of sending my script around as
an actor trying to get financing or just
attention at all and i put together you
know i hired a casting director and i
found a location and i kind of had a
time frame and that and then things
started to come together then it started
to be a reality for agencies and so i
started to see lists
and i saw these actors names um
and it was you know it was extraordinary
um so we would take a chance and have
you know you know sort of luck out and i
you know i sort of i
had a call or i met with martha plimpton
sort of down the street from here i had
coffee with jason isaacs
linda was was
the hardest role i never for some reason
could see the the you know i always had
actors in my head writing i never had
that for linda i think it's possibly the
complexity and sort of how challenging
the role is i'm not really sure
i like to think that i needed to have
the location in the other three you know
after all these characters are visiting
linda right it's where she lives not the
other characters so i think there might
have been something to that um but of
course uh got this incredible person and
i want to speak i have to say you know
she
this idea of this sort of crash course
and intimacy that we tried to have in
this rehearsal process you know i knew
we have to get really close we have to
be an ensemble and actors are kind of
incredible the way they want to be an
ensemble they sort of want to be a
family
and i i was hoping that i could sort of
start that and break the ice by being
vulnerable myself but but anne really
led the way and and really sort of made
that rehearsal process as such as
successful as it was i'm not just saying
that because she's here it's the truth
we talk about it all the time behind my
back you have no idea oh disgrace but um
but no these i'll tell you that you know
another thing that it was table work the
rehearsal right we just went through the
text to try to rewrite things to make
you know the journey more clear to you
know really listen to their instincts
and re you know just rework things to
make it you know so they had what they
needed but ryan jackson healy my
cinematographer was also there to
testing camera lenses and it just sort
of fit and it was just a nice
coincidence that most of the movie is at
a table so we were able to sort of shoot
and test out our shots while they
rehearsed and kind of talk through the
text and i remember about a week later
ryan sent me this dropbox and i just sat
there watching and
i just i knew we had it you know because
i could i could see right there i
thought oh my gosh this is going to be
this is going to be special they're so
good can i say one thing you know i just
thought of this
friend
i i received the script
from my agent and manager
i knew nothing about it
uh
and i knew when i read it of course i
would do it
and worried also
you know was i
up to
what was necessary there the
you know they're living in that level of
grief in a way that would respect
character and story and so on but i had
no desire to talk to you uh first
do you know what i mean i didn't want to
have a lot of chatter about it
i just knew uh
okay all in just tell me when to come
and uh i just loved i loved that
the simplicity of it you know
that makes any sense no no no yeah there
was there wasn't a great deal other than
that rehearsal
i tried to stay out of the room you know
we tried to treat it almost like a love
scene sort of like the only the
essential people should be in the room i
had my first ad i said you call action
you call cut like i'll come in if i
absolutely have to hair and makeup don't
do last looks unless it's absolutely
necessary like wardrobe continuity i
know they touched your scarf a lot but
you know and the effort was to leave
them alone and kind of create a
theatrical like experience for them as
they did these 15 20 minute takes just
let them exist in the world you know and
that we did our preparation before
arriving you know yeah it's very well
thought out yeah it's it's clear
i'm only going to ask one more question
and then i want to open it up to you
also start thinking about what you want
to ask um these two but ann i'd be
curious to know when you did read the
script when gary sent it to you um
i'm back i'm back when you when you read
the script what was your reaction
specifically to the beautiful kind of
coda moment that your character linda
has at the end where she does come back
to tell
that powerful story
what was your reaction to that well it
was all foreign to me
i know that sounds odd but i did not
know who she was i knew that i was very
drawn to her
and wanted to know her but i didn't
know
how would she speak
or or or anything
or what that ending meant
none of those things came into
any clarity until we were doing it be
honest with you yeah i mean i did my
private work which right however one
does you know so what what answers did
you come to then
after
after embodying her
i think she's an extraordinary person
i think
when a life shatters as hers did
i guess you could go a couple of ways
couldn't you you could build the wall
back
up defend
close down
push away
she does none of that
i was very
moved by her
i learned things from her
she's a very powerful presence
i'm grateful to her
what would you all like to know
yes i see a hand right here you have
amazing hair
oh my gosh
i have one of friends teachers here you
must be awful proud of him
oh no
oh that's so cool so
you couldn't hear friends former video
teacher very rightly is asking about the
use of camera and sound and how no i
have to say it's so lovely to see you i
will talk i um
i uh the last movie i ever made was in
your class you know and i
i dreamed about making movies my whole
life and i i would sit around thinking
what the hell are you doing why why
aren't you following this dream of yours
why aren't you making this effort and
you know that last insane movie i made
with gary lundy and our like final
project um
but no truly i thought i i thought about
that a lot anyway um just you know come
on do do it already and um
so yes so the idea was a couple thoughts
i guess i knew this was an endurance
test
so i knew we had to start very wide very
still very simple simple composition we
talked a lot about yasujiro ozu um
this japanese director and in and you
know he's sort of known for these kind
of you know simplistic geometric nice
compositions and presenting life
um
and uh there's a there's real references
the first time you see the room
it's a tatami shot and so something sort
of he coined of sort of it's as if
you're sitting on a tatami mat at your
eye level as if you were sitting on the
floor that's how we sort of present the
room first but you notice if you if you
notice the first close-ups reserved for
martha plympton the grieving mother um
so we're slowly easing into the movie um
and once we're in the room we had a very
simple setup you know we didn't want to
overthink it we talked a lot about my
dinner with andre um and that here's a
movie that works and it's just about
five or six setups you know it's just a
couple two shots i mean a two shot and
some singles like let's not overthink it
and reinvent the wheel i don't know what
i'm doing i'm a first-time director i
don't want to kind of you know overreach
here but we'd had this system and we'd
kind of move
maybe clockwise with the sun you know
and kind of find you know we'd end
shooting up against the wall where we
didn't need sun
so we tried figured out a system
and then each day we'd sort of add new
language to it so we'd add sort of
subtle movement you know when the
photographs start being shared we're so
we started little little movements that
sort of enters the the language and the
idea was that we're trying to mirror and
reflect the sort of emotional journey of
the conversation the sort of emotional
state of the characters they're more
actively searching we're going to be a
little more focused with our more
purposeful with our movement eventually
we have very like sort of
steady you know or conspicuous pans
right and then eventually when jason
isaac stands up to get some water and
he's more frustrated that's they've
reached this impasse we kind of shift
into handheld you know and deteriorate
and then ultimately there's an aspect
ratio shift where we went from spherical
lenses to anamorphic lenses
and that was the idea is that when this
happened
uh their world changed forever and and
and when you lose someone dear to you or
some tragedy real tragedy hits your life
it changes the way you see the world
grief changes you and your perspective
and so we wanted to we wanted to reflect
that with a camera change
shift right so when jason tells
the retells the the events you know the
day and the you know the details of the
day
uh we go to that field once we're back
we're in this kind of new emotional
realm and we're in an anamorphic lens
for the rest of the rest of the movie so
the whole idea was sort of to you know
follow their journey but it was very
much thinking about how do we keep the
audience with us for in a room for you
know it's i think a 75 minute scene you
know so yeah that's impressive
who else has a question
the question is about the challenges of
this particular subject matter and how
he approached it given all the kind of
minefield yeah and what kind of research
should he do
yeah i'm talking to more people now than
i did before i have you know on honestly
front of my mind is is concern and and i
think a healthy amount of insecurity
around the fact that i've never
experienced you know anything like what
is depicted in the movie um i honestly
it it i was my daughter was one and a
half when parkland happened i had to
pull over on the side of the street near
like westwood i was so overwhelmed
listening to this parent and that never
had happened to me you know i was 18
when columbine happened i know exactly
where i was so this has been
my adult life has been these things
right but this was so different i think
as a parent
and i i that night was on amazon
ordering books about columbine and um
sandy hook and virginia tech and aurora
and norway i mean it just went on and on
and i was just sort of obsessed
and then i came across these meetings
and the meetings were something that i i
thought back to the truth and
reconciliation commission that i learned
about in college in south africa and
these
this idea of restorative justice and
forgiveness and reconciliation
families of victims with perpetrators
and that was something that had honestly
troubled me because i didn't think i was
capable of that i didn't think i could
participate in that and so so much of
this movie was this sort of personal
exploration into
what would i do how how could i how
could i do this how what would happen to
me you know so so it felt very desperate
i mean very often this movie felt like i
was kind of making it like my life
depended on it or something you know
what i mean so so it was there was an
urgency to it
would which very often i was
uh
cognizant of the minefield and still am
you know we had the honor of meeting a
parent uh who lost her daughter and uh
at sandy hook and it was you know it was
incredible i spoke with i've spoken with
a couple um
gun violence prevention you know
programs and non-profits you know now
now more now i'm doing more of that
there were a couple people mostly if
anything i spoke with journalists i knew
dave cullen who wrote columbine
i spoke with matthew lisiak who wrote
about newtown so i i had angles that way
but
now we seem to be getting
uh we're getting to experience um you
know actually meeting you know survivors
so i hope that sort of
restfully answered some of it i saw
another hand about halfway back
okay sir
yeah no no yeah i mean i'm gonna have to
answer for this you know to the forever
i um
you know the cross on the wall we
couldn't take down
we asked and we couldn't take it down
it was it was bolted to the wall
um
this reverend you know mother leah koval
who
you know in many ways i i could credit
this entire movie to her because you
know i i was on google looking up
churches like i had nowhere to i had no
idea
where to go and this this woman saw me
staring through her window and called me
in and it sort of was this kind of
destiny there um
i uh i look i to me i mentioned the
truth and reconciliation commission i i
use this quote a lot so i
desmond tutu and his book no future
without forgiveness said the
forgiveness reconciliation and
reparation are not the normal currency
of political discourse they're far more
at home in a religious realm and to me
this movie had to be in a spiritual
setting i never had any question about
it um i was raised catholic i'm not
religious i don't go to church you know
that sort of faded away in my life and
but i i appreciate
many of the values and stories that come
out of the bible i sort of i i don't i
think it's wise to just sort of dismiss
them so i i'm not afraid of the
religious connotation you know i i i
welcome it but i think what's really
happening is that
these four characters are are trying to
make sense of the unexplainable and find
meaning and something that you you just
can't really ever understand and i think
it's it is a spiritual pursuit i think
the movie is heavily spiritual given
that it's about life and death and grief
and loss and forgiveness and so you know
that was my kind of comfort zone and my
upbringing the church but maybe if i was
jewish it would have been in a temple
but there was never any question in my
mind that it had to have a spiritual
element now i try to make a point that
the the reverend's not there they're in
the parish hall they're doing sort of
human work it's secular work of just
working through their pain
but you know spirituality is sort of
around the corner you know this sort of
opportunity to have a relationship with
it is sort of
nearby you know so it felt entirely
right
the minute we walked in
that it would be in that room
uh
spirit present so to speak
it's god adjacent this one got adjacent
she calls it i push back and say god is
always present however i like that
adjustment it's nice
i um my job is to keep ann and fran on
the schedule they're very much in demand
this evening they have another event to
go to so we have to end it here but i
want to thank all of you for being here
for your questions and and out and frank
so much thank you so much
[Music]